what do you say to people who look at
what happened with regard sheer heart
attack look at the fact that you're the
oldest candidate in the race and wonder
if you have the stamina for four years
in office so what I say is you look at
the totality of a candidate this is a
record based on thirty and forty years
of fighting for the working families of
this country that's my record
congresswoman I know when the senator
was in the hospital and Nevada you
called him I did is that when you
offered your endorsement yes why in that
moment I think it was a gut check for me
you know it was a real gut check and
it's saying and and by the way neither
me nor the senator cannot do this by
ourselves what does having her
endorsement mean it's it's very
significant Alexandria has been a
political phenomenon it is hard to
believe that she has been in office for
less than one year and yet she has
helped transform politics in America she
has been an inspiration to millions of
working people and young people
throughout this country and her addition
to this campaign is very very
significant we're delighted to have
Rockwood
congresswoman why Bernie what Bernie
represents is a complete change in
politics in America one that focuses on
the betterment of life for working
people first and foremost one that
values education housing health care is
right one that says America is not going
to dedicate itself to endless wars but
to the establishment of peace and
prosperity worldwide and that not only
that that's what we want to achieve but
we're going to achieve it by having a
revolution of working people at the
ballot box and that is just something I
want to be a part of I know you all met
about a month ago at a Burlington diner
you're here sitting together and now how
did this all come about I think it
probably came about over many many many
years actually you know exam three elect
at the world as it is and she believes
that millions of people got to stand up
and fight for justice I'm just a little
bit older than she is and I've been
looking at that world for many many
decades and I think what we agree on is
that health care is a human right that
we will not tolerate the level of income
and wealth inequality which exists in
this country where half of our people
live in paycheck to paycheck while three
people are more well from the bottom
half of America so these are the ideas
that she embedded into herself and I did
and it's just the coming together of two
people look at the world in a very
similar way
congresswoman why endorse now it's still
very early in the race it is very early
anti
what's important too is you know for me
there's some folks that try to make
these decisions by making political
calculations and looking at political
strategy but I think for me once I've
decided what I want to do I think it's
just the most authentic decision to let
people know how I feel and where I am
and as the senator mentioned last
February I was waitressing in a
restaurant in downtown Manhattan and I
didn't have health insurance and I
wasn't being paid a living wage and I
was facing sexual harassment at work and
to think now that I'm on the other side
of this as a member of Congress and
understanding the pressures there are on
the inside to conform and to have seen
them and experience them firsthand
it's astounded me frankly that the
senator has been there fighting for me
long before I got to the halls of
Congress you made history with your
election and you both are part of the
most diverse Congress in history this is
also the most diverse Democratic
presidential field ever I'm gonna be a
little blunt with you congresswoman and
don't take offense senator but as a
woman of color why back an old white guy
and is this the future of the party yeah
you know I think I'm actually very
excited about this partnership because
it shows what we have to do
in our country is that we have to come
together across race across gender
across generation and across across
class in order to establish our basic
systems as rights is there something you
weren't hearing from the other
candidates namely the candidates of
color the female candidates in the race
first and foremost I think that my
decision is not about any other
candidate not being good I don't think
that in order for us to focus on these
issues we have to put anybody anyone
else down that said the senator how he's
going about this is very important is
that he is going into places he goes
into deep red states he goes into
forgotten communities when he campaigned
in 2016 he was one of the first
presidential candidates since Bobby
Kennedy during his campaign to come to
the South Bronx and that spoke to me
because
that kind of commitment is what we need
in the United States and frankly I have
confidence that at the end of this
primary we're all going to come together
to defeat Donald Trump and not just to
defeat Donald Trump but to defeat the
systems of which he is a symptom the
corruption of our politics the the
profound racism and classism that that
he takes advantage of in order to
succeed did you meet with other
candidates before making your decision I
did yes senator Warren yes what was that
conversation like you know I think she's
a fabulous candidate and frankly senator
Sanders senator Warren and myself are
all on the same team in the party we are
all part of this progressive wing and
I'm just thankful that we're all here in
this together did you notify her before
signing on with senator sam-i-am I had a
conversation and what was that
conversation like you know we talked
about how we're going to come together
as a movement and we talked about how
our movements our shared values and
we're here and we're committed to
progress and you know as for senator
Sanders he's been fighting for me my
entire life and I would like the
opportunity to fight for her if the
senator is not the nominee will you
eventually support the Democratic
nominee of course so senator Warren as a
nominee yopo I don't think there's any
doubt that every candidate running for
president will support the eventual
winner obviously I hope it's me if it's
not me we're gonna rally together around
whoever it may be because we understand
that Donald Trump is most dangerous
president perhaps in the history of this
country and he must be defeated I think
that's a consensus held by every
candidate running for president and that
includes supporting Jill Biden every
candidate we're going to rally around
whoever that candidate is but the bottom
line is to me we've got to do two things
in this campaign number one we have to
defeat Trump and I happen to believe
that I am the strongest candidate who is
able to do that but second of all
defeating Trump is not enough we have
got to transform our economy we've got
to transform our government and make
sure that we have a nation now that is
working for all people and not just the
1% and one of the reasons I'm so excited
that Alexandria is on what is that she
has the capability and it's already done
it reached out the people who are
marginalized people who don't get
involved in the political process and
the only way in my view that we beat
Trump is through a campaign of energy
and excitement we have millions of
people young people working people poor
people who have not been involved in
politics are going to stand up and say
you know what this is our country and
it's not just the country of the 1% and
I think with Alexandria on board we're
gonna rally those people and win this
campaign if you are the nominee senator
would you consider the congresswoman as
your running mate
there you go she's incident but let me
tell you this I happen to think as I
said earlier that if you appreciate that
she has been in public life for less
than a year and has been the lead on so
many issues when you talk about the
green New Deal that's her tackling the
existential threat of climate change
coming up with the program rallying
people all over this country first year
in Congress that is quite impressive
if the senator is elected would you work
in a Sanders administration of Sanders
Whitehouse you know I always wake up
every morning yes you would I think for
me I just wake up every morning and I
say how can I do the most good and so
you know that decision should you know
we get to it she asked something I would
consider
to look at
immediate step right now our next
immediate step is to expand this
electorate to turn out the vote to
defeat Donald Trump and to make sure
that we establish in America that treats
housing education health care and our
climate future as right what role will
you play in this campaign will we see
you out at the rallies out on the stone
yeah I hope so and and I you know the
role that I that I hope to play is to
really talk to people who are in coach
in my own campaign last year we expanded
the electorate 68% over the last year
midterm primary and my past my passion
is just talking to people who don't
follow my passion is discussing and
engaging people in very real ways
because there's a misperception that
people who don't vote are uneducated or
apathetic but more often than that than
not people who don't vote are just sick
of our politics and our system and they
want someone who's really going to to
change out our capital and our politics
and so
with that I'm looking forward to
expanding that electorate not just to
elect senator Sanders but to elect
hundreds if not thousands of people down
the ballot across the country from City
Council and school boards all the way up
to Congress in terms of the campaign
senator year obviously running to take
on President Trump but congresswoman do
you feel like you're already on the
ticket given how much the president
talks about you on Twitter yeah and you
know as we've seen with a lot of
reporting he he has specifically been
ramping up his attacks on women and
people of color even many of us who
aren't in the presidential field he's
actually been increasing his attacks on
on those folks because his prime and
primary focus is to divide and frankly
to to ratchet up fear amongst white
Americans amongst older Americans into
division and we have to
remind our country that we will not be
divided along those grounds and in fact
we will Center the needs of people who
need it exactly alexandria said it
better tonight
Trump is trying to divide us up based on
the color of our skin where we were born
a religion of sexual orientation and
that's how he thinks he's gonna win
reelection but I got big news for him
that ain't gonna happen and what our
campaign is about is exactly the
opposite it is bringing our people
together those are our people and our
people all over this country around an
agenda that speaks to the needs of
working people many of whom have been
neglected for years and that's how we're
gonna win this election